[Music]
we're joined now by trevor phillips
times columnist
former head of the equality and human
rights commission trevor welcome back to
spectator tv now you'll have seen
research this week indicating that
nearly three-quarters of black
bricks wouldn't take the vaccine
do you do you think it's really that
high
yes i do i think that there probably is
a very high level
of vactine vaccine reluctant or vaccine
skepticism amongst minorities
and i make the distinction because
reluctance
is really about lack of knowledge or
lack of understanding skepticism is
something
rather more conscious and positive
and i think amongst some minorities
there is a significant level
of skepticism they know perfectly well
what's being said about it they just
don't agree with it
what's the the cause of this uh
skepticism
uh if if to use your word because it is
quite marked i see from this research
72 of black britons
unlikely to get vaccinated they claim
42 percent of those from pakistan and
bangladesh origin
it's still a high number but it's a lot
lower than 72
but also some quite high what can i call
it anti-vac sentiment
among east europeans too now that's
quite a varied group from
black britons to to british
citizens of pakistani in bangladesh
origin to those from east european
what what's causing the skepticism in
your view
well i think there are a couple of
things going on here and i'll just
preface it by saying
that a big part of this problem is that
the government
and the authorities have made a big play
in the last six or seven months
of saying how much they recognize
that ethnic minorities are more
susceptible or more at risk
actually they don't know that they
haven't really done
the work we don't know the data uh the
government
says this stuff but actually it can't
back it up and i can go into more detail
if you want oh i understand
why that's why that's such a big problem
uh
because it's a big issue in convincing
some of these groups
why do i think that there is vaccine
reluctance or skepticism well first of
all
i just don't buy this idea that's being
put around and ministers say this
that oh it's all about language and the
communication's not reaching them
if you look at the ons data the
proportion of people in this country who
do not speak english well enough
to understand that kind of information
is about what is 1.3
the highest level of language lack of
language proficiency
is uh bangladeshi women five percent
so this idea that basically it's all
about giving it the information to them
in their languages and so on brackets
they're all a bit backward
i just hate i really despise it because
actually it's a good way for official
them
to pretend that actually it's the fault
of these
minority communities and secondly what
it suggests
is that these people just don't know
what's going on if they
you know if we educated them a bit
better they they'd think the same as us
and it's a failure to recognize that
actually some of the
communities involved just take a
different
view about risk and about levels
of uh the value of vaccine and there's
one other thing which may explain
partly why the black figure let's call
it
though that covers a whole multitude of
kinds of people is so high
and that is simply distrust of authority
uh something similar is true in the
united states where african americans
are displaying significant levels of
resistance
to taking the vaccine and what we think
is going on there is very simply
we don't believe you and actually uh
everything you've done in the past has
really shafted us
and there's one other small point which
perhaps um
we ought to think about um and which you
know i'm i'm
completely pro the vaccine well one of
the questions that one might
ask actually if you were from some
minority backgrounds is
has this been tested on people like me
and actually what we know about the way
that the
pharma company carry out their testing
is that they always do
have uh a deficit in
the proportion of people from minorities
you're a another distinguished british
uh
citizen from a caribbean background jeff
palmer so jeff hammer who uh was writing
in the mail
this week he also mentioned the issue of
trust
um he also wrote and i've
remained to be convinced about this you
take that there were
there were just too many white people up
on that stage
from public school backgrounds and that
was the reason
can can that really explain 72 percent
well uh full disclosure jeff um
has been a family friend interestingly
enough
from the time he was a great friend of
mine
older brother so i've known him since i
was six years old
and i have great regard for him i think
he's a
you know he's a brilliant scientist and
so forth i think he's got his
got it around his neck on this one i
think actually the idea that if you just
had a few black faces on the platform
uh it's a variety of the same thing
that actually um if you
basically talk to the chiefs then the
chiefs will talk to the indians
and then it'll all be all right
i just think this is nonsense the truth
of the matter is that people are fully
conscious by and large
of what they're being told but
in for substantial reasons some to do
with cultural background maybe religious
beliefs
but also skepticism about what they're
being told by
any authority in this country they are
not
convinced why does this matter well it
matters because if you're going to
remedy
that simply to giving them the same
information
just in another language isn't going to
crack it you've got to address
the fact that people have different
points of view and this in a way goes to
the heart of a debate that we've been
having 20 years about multiculturalism
that you know you can all go kumbaya and
say okay we're all
the same under the skin and all the rest
of it but there will come a moment
and we may be coming to one where what
we discover
is that there are some people who
sincerely believe something
which is completely at odds with what
the
majority of the country believes and
what the majority of the country
believes
to be at odds with the interest of the
community as a whole
and at that point somebody's got to make
a decision
about how you deal with that
well to ask my favorite leninist
question
what is to be done
well i think uh the first thing is that
we you know you know that i bang on
about this
we've got to have proper information i
mean right now
everybody says constantly uh their
minorities are at greater risk well
actually the latest data
from the nhs on mortality shows
that the proportion of people who have
died who are white
is 86 percent which is exactly
the number that white people represent
in the population as a whole
so first of all we need to stop uh
spinning a narrative which is basically
the one that people would like to
to be true because it solves all sorts
of problems and deal with the fact and
that needs some work
secondly um and and also if you're going
to persuade people you've got to show
them some actual data
so i would say that we first need to
understand
who is at risk and secondly we need to
understand better
which communities are truly reluctant
saying black people are more reluctant
which includes somalis and ghanaians
and bardems who all have completely
different outlooks
you know some might be muslims some
might be christians we need to
understand
who is really vaccine skeptic and
why before we uh tackle the problem
so i think we need to do a bit more
research and be a bit more honest about
this before we start throwing solutions
which frankly will have no impact into
the pot i mentioned that i was a
skeptical of jeff palmer's complaint
about too many white too many public
school boys giving out the message
um but i do also see there is some
validity
in giving up messages to particular
groups
in the the in the manner
in the language by people that they
regard as role models and
that they look up to as exemplars of the
communities
that they come from and i'm not sure the
government has done much
or any of that i mean i know he's a busy
young man with a lot to do already but
someone like marcus rashford
uh or stonzie even people like that they
could they not make a difference if the
government got them on side on this
only if they actually had a proper
answer i mean the fact that somebody is
black
is telling you something that you think
is nonsense
isn't going to persuade you any more
than if somebody is white gives you
something an answer that you think is
nonsense i think
whoever the messenger is we've got to
get the message
right first and my concern here
is that uh the way we're dealing with
this
somehow suggests that the only reason
that people might be vaccine
skeptic is because they just don't
understand
modern white people's ways i think we
first
have to address what is it that they
actually
are concerned about and make sure that
we actually have a proper answer
by the way i mean one of the other
things that's being said is it's all
about the conspiracy theories that are
going around
and that actually somehow minorities are
more susceptible to conspiracy theories
on twitter
i mean give me a break give me i mean
you know so first of all i think the
fundamental thing is i i get your point
but the first thing is treat the
minority
skepticism with the seriousness it
deserves
listen to why people think that there's
a problem
and answer it scientifically with proper
data if we can
who gives a message i don't care about
you may be right marcus ratford would be
more listened to than anybody else but
actually i'm not sure that's true
i think that the average minority person
will say
marcus rashford knows about football but
he absolutely does not know about
sticking
needles in my arm so the messenger does
matter
but what matters more is the message i
understand well we know government
people watch spectator tv so i hope they
were listening to you trevor
from what you had to say there thanks
for joining us again my pleasure as
always andrew thank you
[Music]
you